what is up everybody we are back in the
studio i can't believe it's so good to
see you
why am i in the studio why am i so
excited we don't want to screw this one
up because i'm a big fan of his
and we're gonna get into who our guest
is today you guys are in for a treat
make sure you let a couple of friends
know clear out your table i know you're
at home we're all kind of locked up
but maybe this is a little break that
you needed today this is a
this is a moment because i'm a fan of
his and the beauty of the internet is
i get to reach out to people and
sometimes they're like hey yeah let's go
do this thing
so on today's show we're going to be
talking to pierre
cline house and here's a little bit of
what i know about him
he's an award-winning freelance
illustrator and designer he's based out
of
israel and i hear that it's very warm
there right now
luckily it's not as hot for us here and
he's worked with some really cool
clients and i don't know how to say this
is it stella
artois broadway theater affinity
designer harpercollins
bbc focus and many more just to wet your
appetite a little bit
here's a sample of some of his work and
there were so many things i could have
grabbed but
look at this stuff i love it because
it's beautiful it's graphic it's got a
cool style
it's it's fun it's whimsical and it's
simple
and there's so many things i love about
this so on today's show we're going to
get a little
bit into his personal story his insights
and the special treat he's going to be
doing a live illustration demo
pierre kleinhouse welcome to the show
hey chris thanks for having me of course
thanks for doing this i'm so excited to
talk to you today
oh my god yeah i really hope my english
works
when i'm excited if it doesn't we will
fill in for you we'll fill in some of
the gaps
so i understand you want to tell us a
little like
are you going to do a little uh a deck
presentation are you just going to talk
well i have just like a few tips
and uh sort of like a process breakdown
that i thought i'll share with you guys
okay um
yeah it's not really like about like my
personal story that much but
uh i mean we can talk about it also if
you want to like beforehand
well maybe yeah whatever feels good and
comfortable for you
yeah sure so why don't we get into this
how do you describe what you do um
i'm an illustrator but
i mean i study graphic design and
illustration and i feel like
my sweet spot is you know the connection
between
illustration and branding and graphic
design basically um yeah
so uh because yeah cause illustration
can
can go into a lot of different areas
uh so i guess i'm more into like the
places where it connects with
graphic design and uh yeah i guess you
can you can
you can see it in my work like i'm
mostly concerned about like the
composition
and uh that's like the first thing i'm
always thinking about
yeah i see for sure and that's why i'm
drawn to it because
the world of illustrators and in terms
of like
how many illustrators out there it's
vast and there's so many and it's kind
of hard to stand out
i like your use of color simple shapes
and you do things
very graphic so it doesn't surprise me
that you said you studied graphic design
but
here's the part that i hate about you
that you can actually draw people wonder
this all the time can designers draw
and do you have to draw to be a designer
first of all yes some designers are
talented like that they can draw
case in point and you do not have to
know how to draw to be a graphic
designer although i think it's an
advantage to be able to draw
yeah totally and i gotta say like i
never felt
like when i when i was a kid or like
teenager
i never felt like i can draw very good
and
i didn't even think about it like when i
when i
decided to go to the university and
actually study graphic design it was
because
i felt like that's the closest thing i
can i can do
that relates to illustration i mean i
really liked you know comic
comic books and mangas and anime and all
that stuff but
um i i didn't think i can actually
like you know have a career drawing
stuff so
that's why i applied to graphic design
actually so it's
i mean you can practice you can learn
you know it's
it takes time you know you know what i
also like that you share videos
on on youtube and on social where i can
see you working through the problem
so you'll do something like oh that's
pretty cool and then you'll change it
and
you'll add texture or you'll change the
way the fur is rendered and
you you'll take it away and you'll do it
a different way i really like seeing
that because
i learned something i get to see your
thinking process kind of laid out before
us
finally you mentioned that because that
was like totally like a mistake
uh i tried to make like the process
video
uh like at the beginning i tried to make
them very
like smooth and you know like this
perfect process and then
sometimes it just doesn't work for me
and then after posting a few of those
processes that didn't really work well
uh
i just realized you know i got so many
positive comments uh
about these videos and the reactions are
just
i i guess people more like connect
better when they actually see like a
real process
and not like the perfect timelapse that
you can find sometimes on instagram so
uh definitely by mistake like it
happened and now i'm
now it's like a part of my videos i
guess
that's very cool so it started out as
like you you wanted to edit it out but
there it was and
now people like it so this is a really
great part because i think a lot of us
are afraid of putting out work that may
or may not be perfect quote unquote
i don't believe that you can't actually
make something perfect and then what we
wind up doing is sharing a process and
being real and being authentic and
genuine and people really
connect to that and they're learning
more because it's not always a straight
line
sometimes i've seen you work rework
things like three or four times i was
like i was happy with the first version
but just seeing you work through the
process and iterative cycles that you go
through
are really super cool so again another
great reason
so i i wanna i wanna stop talking for a
second here
i wanna get into the oh shoot are they
saying that there's a problem here
jonah what please check it out yeah
ultra design is saying we have an issue
with the audio video sync
okay i'll work on that okay thanks for
letting us know about the
the audio video thing so before we we go
further we'll make sure that jonah
rectifies him
okay yeah people are saying there's a
audio video delay
all right we just fixed it hopefully
okay jonah just fixed it
all right uh i think i just saw tristan
on here
uh okay or sean i forget how okay
anyways
it's easy design thank you very much so
hopefully the audio is fixed right now
and why don't we do this why don't we
get
why don't we get into your insights what
have you learned or
can you share what your creative process
looks like
yeah sure so uh let me share the slides
that i have
okay with you guys uh just a sec let me
share my screen
okay all right so
um can you see my screen i can yeah
awesome so uh well basically basically
it's just like a couple of tips
and a personal story which is kind of
funny and embarrassing so
i thought i'd share it here and um i
mean these are very basic tips
nothing very sophisticated but
i mean i guess i'm a simple guy and
these work for me so
why not share share them with you so
the first one is about using uh local
references
which i think is really handy sometimes
and i did this design
this it's a gig poster design for a
festival
a local festival here in israel and it's
a very small festival it's something
in my hometown which is like super small
it's not even a town and
i just love this festival it's like my
favorite thing it happens like every
year
and you know there's live music there's
bands
it's been organized by this record vinyl
shop
um so uh there's like special edition
buying records and stuff and people come
in the families
it's very like uh homey and warm and i
just really love this festival and i've
been doing posters for them for a few
years
and i usually just do whatever i wanted
with this poster because
the brief was fairly open but
then i i felt like i want to do um
the next poster and you know kind of
relate
and connect with this festival and kind
of represent it in the poster so
um i usually start working in my
sketchbook
i don't know if you can really
understand anything from this sketch
but uh it's it's basically like a guy
holding a guitar
i see it uh yeah so yeah sometimes the
sketches are like super messy and
um it's just you know just a way to come
with ideas fast
and for me you know once i have like an
interesting idea
i'll move to uh photoshop and then i'll
actually come up with the final
composition because i think
it's just way faster um and i can just
you know
play with the typography and make sure
everything is in place
instead of redrawing this sketch like 10
times in my sketchbook you know
um i can just do it really fast in
photoshop and
i guess again this is where like my
graphic designer kicks in
and i i mean for me it's like the most
important part
of the process like to nail down the
composition and feel like
everything is in place um so at this
point i'm also
i also included like the the details
like the the title the date and the
band's
names here at the bottom and
then i moved on to the coloring process
i'll usually work very clean with like a
pen tool
or like just like simple vector shapes
geometric shapes and once i
you know i'll go from the big shapes to
the smaller shapes and then i'll add
some more details um and work with
textures and brushes and stuff
that's like my my normal process like
most of the time
and you know as i work on it i'll
sometimes
change things like the heads or like i
use
like a different reference for the head
and actually use like photo references
for the
the feet and the hands of the guy this
time
um but i i'm like sometimes i do it
sometimes i don't really do it
my style is kind of weird that way i
mean the dog here is
not really realistic but uh yeah it's
just kind of a
weird mix i guess can i ask you a
question can you go back to that slide
go back one slide
where where do you get the style from
like
his beard his hair this guy with a torn
shirt
and sitting on a log is this actually
something you saw or is it a composite
of many things
because i think you have a very
interesting and unique style that's just
very alluring to me
awesome so you open the door for my tip
basically
um so i'm just gonna jump into here
okay um oh i see so it's i
that's that's like the whole tip
basically it's about finding like real
references
that will make you work uh just a bit
more unique i mean
this is actually the guys who are coming
to these events uh
this is like real photos from like
previous festivals and you can see like
someone from the band
sitting bare feet uh playing the guitar
and people actually come with their dogs
to the festival
and so i thought like mixing all of
these things together will make it's
just
more appealing for the audience to
actually know what this festival is all
about
and and then i actually realized i can
actually
add these uh finding records that are
being chopped away from the tree log and
then this is kind of a reference for the
organizer of the festival which is the
final record shop
so i think that you know using all these
references that are actually based on
something
uh real just make it super unique and
then
if i think about like if another
designer from
i don't know from finland or from china
will design his own poster and use his
own references
things are gonna look way different and
i think that's like the most important
and like most interesting thing you can
do you know as a designer i see
good tip i i like that uh clever i
didn't realize it at first but the
the cutting away the log making the
records
that's pretty cool yeah it actually kind
of came
came to me as i was working on it it
wasn't like there originally or
it wasn't even sketch but yeah sometimes
yeah it happens
nice as you work on stuff yeah
so yeah that's like the first tip uh
should i go to the next one yeah okay so
the
next one is basically the same almost
the same but
it's about using uh you know coming up
with your own references
so um i'm just going to show you another
process basically
so okay this time it's uh
it's a greeting card that i designed and
illustrated for
um like this exhibition in tel aviv
and it was organized by a studio that
makes fonts
mostly hebrew fonts so
the brief was to create a greeting card
and
basically do whatever i want as long as
i use the font one of their fonts
in the in the greeting card and then
you know i always do like a research uh
at the beginning of the process and i i
looked up like okay
what are like the most common jewish
greeting cards for the new year and this
is what i came up with
and you know these are great these are
awesome but you know it's not really
um it's not really the type of
illustration i'm interested in doing so
so i guess you know sometimes you get
stuck with like
projects that you don't really know how
you can actually connect
personally with like with the brief um
and this is where like this tip comes
handy for me
sorry this is something i like to do
from time to time and
um i just decided to come up with my own
references
from japanese art actually because i
really like
personally like i i
as a teenager i really like manga and
anime and this is one of like the
main reasons i actually went to study
graphic design illustrations so
um you know wood block prints like these
from like 400 years ago this is like my
favorite art
ever and i thought like why not
actually mix it with the local
references i already have
from the jewish new year reading cards
and
so this is the final greeting card that
i came up with
and i just think you know it's it's
a mix of you know both world and i think
this is what makes it very
unique to me personally because again
there's not many illustrator designers
who actually have
you know uh both of both of these
reference
um you know i'm i'm interested in japan
i live here and you know i use the honey
and the pomegranate
that are like very famous symbols for
the holiday
i use the hebrew typography that says
like happy new year
but i also you know use like colors from
based on this print
and i use a tiger and i think it just
makes things like
weird and interesting and it's just like
a cool trick that i actually use
from time to time i guess who got you
into the japanese woodblock prince
so um i actually i mean i didn't know
about it like before
studying i always liked you know manga
and anime
and that's definitely what pushed me
over to study graphic design and then
like
i remember just finding like this huge
book in the library in the university
with all these prints um and actually
i scanned them
which is very old school i guess right
scanned a lot of these prints and saved
them on my computer
but yeah that's like how i uh
like discovered this this amazing art
i love the fusion of the two cultures
and how you interpret it through your
lens i think that's a great way to come
up with a unique style
thanks so much
so uh should i go through the
impressionable story now
yeah let's do it you have any questions
yeah let's let's go for this
yeah yeah okay so this is just like i
mean it doesn't really
connect specifically to illustration i
mean just just an interesting story
about
faking it until you make it i guess or
as you like to say chris uh believe it
until you achieve it right right right
you're paying attention thank you oh man
i didn't say this so yeah i'm a huge fan
of the future
and i love your your videos and
really helped me a lot i think you know
when i got started in
you know being a freelancer and all that
uh so yeah
definitely um so yeah this
this story kind of connects with this
idea of uh
believing until you achieve it so um
well i always i always liked exhibitions
and design events and meetups and stuff
like that and i was always
interested in doing more and i think you
know this is a great way to
actually uh also i mean you can develop
your personal style this way and work on
like interesting
new work that is just for you without a
client and i think
that's really cool and also you know the
fact that you can go outside
your studio and actually meet with other
creators
um i think just like super great and
it's something i always wanted to do
more of
but i i didn't really do anything
big in this area um when i got started
and i
i mean i did some group exhibitions like
small group exhibitions in tel aviv but
that's basically it
um and then i got this interesting uh
invitation from this
woman from milan from italy and she was
organizing a very small
exhibition in milan and she asked me if
i want to
you know do something send it over
basically like over email
and she would print it and use it in the
exhibition so
um i was happy to do it of course i mean
i don't get a lot of invitations from
you know exhibitions uh outside of
israel and
i thought yeah why not like i should do
something new and i came up with these
two illustrations but
uh then i realized like i'm actually
missing the
the best part of the exhibition which is
actually going
to the opening night and meeting all the
other guys
and i mean for me it's like a super
important part and
you know they couldn't afford like you
know fly me over or anything like that
i mean this was a super small exhibition
not even it's nothing
in a gallery even it's like in a small
uh restaurant
something like that so um i
i guess i realized like i'm kind of
stuck in a loop
um where you know i don't i don't have
any experience you know
doing big exhibitions or anything
like that so i don't get new invitations
to do like
bigger exhibitions i guess out of like
other people can relate with this
uh loop situation like when you when
you're looking for your first job
yeah as a designer i mean we all we all
been there i guess so uh i
i thought like maybe this is actually
like a great opportunity for me to
uh do something weird and
i i'll i'll just invite myself to milan
basically
and go to this exhibition so
um i talked to the organizer again i
told her you know what
i'm gonna do another artwork a third
artwork for the exhibition but
this time it's going to be like a
physical drawing like
a big painting and because of it like i
can't send it over like
you know over the email i have to come
there and do it
at the gallery so she told me it's a
great idea
but obviously they can't afford it they
can have me
they can pay for like the expenses and
all that stuff
so i decided that i'm just gonna
come i'm gonna i'm gonna pay for my own
you know flight
uh ticket and hotel and
i'm gonna make it happen you know uh and
i guess i felt like i'm a bit of
fool for doing this um i definitely
remember like speaking with some of my
friends
and i told some of my friends like you
know i'm gonna go to this exhibition and
everybody was super excited at the
beginning
and then when i actually explained like
oh no i'm actually gonna pay for my own
flight right and then people were like
why are you doing this man what's what's
the point
um so i definitely felt like an idiot
uh when i did this but i i just wanted
to experience like
what's it gonna be like and uh meet
these people and
i don't know i just decided to do it
anyway i guess
um and then i actually realized like i i
never drawn by hand before
um i mean i i've been working on the
computer for
uh a few years by then and i
i kind of developed my style using
photoshop
mainly and i realized like if i'm gonna
draw their live at the opening night i
have to kind of
practice at home first so it was
definitely
uh nerve-wracking i mean it was a few
days
where i just couldn't figure it out you
know how to make
this style that i use in the computer
work
when i'm drawing by hand so i it was
it was very uh nerve-wracking but
eventually
i figured it out more or less
so yeah this is just like a few nights
before the event
and yeah i felt like i'm i'm gonna be
okay like it's
it's getting there are you doing this at
home or in the hotel or where are you
doing that's no that's
that's at home okay you're doing this at
home and for everybody that's wondering
this question
what are you using are you using paint
markers how are you doing this
uh that's a great question i actually
had a terrible time with
uh like working with real pain so i
decided
eventually because the details are small
so small and accurate
because of my style i actually use posca
pens for
almost everything yeah so that must have
consumed quite a few pens to be able to
do that right
um i use the big ones um and then i'll
use like
two like one or two for the whole thing
okay basically yeah excellent oh one
more question before we continue because
this is uh from ryan walter he's asking
what tools are you using on the computer
is it photoshop is it illustrators is
something else
most of the time it's uh either
photoshop or affinity designer
okay yeah there you go
all right please continue here we go
okay so um
yes i just wanted to say like you know
sometimes i mean i felt like i'm
stepping out of my
comfort zone it definitely sucked and
again like i felt like i'm doing
something kind of weird but
and then when i got there i i was you
know i got to milan and i was looking
for the gallery the first time
to meet with the organizer and i
remember like it was kind of dark
it was raining and i kind of got lost
for
like five minutes and i
felt like the the the most idiot person
like
in the world you know for doing this and
of course like five minutes later
i met with them and it was amazing and
everything was perfect but
at the moment like it felt really scary
and um
yeah i just wanted to kind of mention it
and but anyway you know the event itself
was like super fun
i had a blast i really enjoyed it
i met with a lot of cool guys and
actually drew live for the first time
and
even like later on when i came back
i realized i actually have now like this
this new
uh technique basically which i
wouldn't have learned otherwise i mean i
had to to have something that kind of
pushed me to
practice and and now it's like my
favorite thing to do is actually to draw
by hand
and i have another process video let's
see if it works
yeah so um
it was really like a bonus thing that
kind of happened because of this
exhibition and
i think that making this transition to
drawing by hand also like
learn me like it got me to
understand better like my my style and
what is actually
important about my illustration and my
style i guess
if that makes sense i mean because you
have to kind of let go of some elements
because you can't do everything by hand
so i think this this whole process
really got me
to understand better like what's what's
my style is all about
i guess so are you saying that the
limitations of drawing things by hand
influence those constraints how much you
can do
right because obviously if you're doing
very technical tight things
it would just be a pain in the butt so
it does it
change the way that you design and think
a little bit
yeah yeah totally um so yeah
even like simple stuff like applying
highlights and shadows i i really like
this
brush that everybody keeps asking me
about this gray uh grainy brush
and it's basically based on these dots
you know making these dots
with the pen um it's basically the same
it's the same thing
keeping it simple and i don't use
any other brush basically just like a
regular brush for lines
and this brush and i i don't know it
kind of makes sense for me
that uh if i'm using the computer
nowadays
i can actually uh do the same thing
almost
just by hand and for me it's it's a cool
thing
i don't know it's just old school
stippling right just adding one dot at a
time
yeah there's no secret it just it's it's
work that's what it is
exactly yeah it's easier with uh with a
computer
but i mean actually the final result
with
with a painting at this size when you
see all the small dots
in real life it's actually much better i
really like it
but i mean yeah you can really see it in
the video i guess
i wanted to ask you the first time you
went to this exhibition you said you
bought your ticket you invited yourself
so
it cost you money to be there and then
you had to learn how to do
traditional media with markers and ink
or paint
did you make any money did you sell that
uh those two drawings or that drawing
that you've shared with us
no no i i i mean oh maybe like
some some people bought a few of the
prints
like just a few like very very small
amount of money but
i i made the uh the calculation i
realized
it's gonna cost me like something like
500 bucks you know to fly over and pay
for
airbnb apartments and i mean i was
working at the time i had
a day job as an illustrator and it felt
like a reasonable amount of money
that i can spend easily yeah so
in terms of like the money it wasn't
like that big um
and uh and i think it really paid off
eventually i mean
uh it's kind of funny you know i came
back and i i was basically the same
person
but i it felt like you know some other
people
maybe clients and just like people who
didn't really know
um you know know me personally yeah
started to see me as i don't know this
really
amazing artist who is you know flying
all over the world for exhibitions so
uh yeah you know that's the part about
you know faking it till you're making it
i guess
um and i don't know kind of it's kind of
funny how things happen but like just a
few months later he worked with this
magazine from brazil which is called
zoopy
and i did this cover for them and had a
nice connection with the other director
and
it is actually organizing these huge
conferences for design and illustration
uh in brazil and he just invited me to
come
and actually give a talk there
um you know i share the same uh
stage with you know stefan segment and
like so many
amazing people so it was like super
crazy
and i don't know like maybe it affected
that
and i mean i started getting these
invitations like afterwards and i
actually got
to uh to do like an exhibition in china
and travel there for like a whole week
and
oh man that was like such an amazing
week um
really really fun and uh interesting
people
and late like later like an year later i
got
to do my first big exhibition uh just
meeting another illustrator from uh
israel in kind of illustration week so
i don't know it felt like one thing kind
of led to the other and
the door was already open once i did
that
and people felt like it's okay
uh to actually um you know
invite me to speak about illustration
and design now the time you know i've
been here and there and
did all this stuff so um i don't know
it's it's a funny story i guess um and
you know here i am speaking to chris now
so wait a minute yeah it's the peak of
my career for sure
down here from here
no there's many more uh tops that you
have yet to see
so this would not be the peak for sure
so
the first exhibition was it 2017.
did i see that date right wow so it's
not even been that long
no no i i went oh my goodness yeah in
2015
okay wow yeah
three yeah the last three years started
it started to get interesting i guess
amazing so i'm sure some people who are
watching this now or later are going to
be punching themselves in their head
like oh my god he's only been doing this
for
a few years and he's already at this
level that's that's fantastic
congrats man thanks so much and thanks
for sharing that
i am older i mean i i mean i started
studying when i was
25 actually so um
wait what did you do before uh you have
to go to the army in israel so i see
yeah so yeah when i was and actually
like i
when i was 23 and i was free and i was
starting to think about
you know what is it that i actually want
to do um i realized like okay i'm gonna
study you know graphic design
and then i actually applied to like
three there's only three uh universities
you can get
uh like actually like a diploma like
i don't know what it's called like an
mba right
in graphic design anyway so i
applied to all these academies
and i basically failed
you know three exams and um
and then i had to spend like another
year and work on my portfolio and take
the exams again
just to start studying so i started
pretty late like twenty
years old yeah okay
fantastic thanks for sharing that story
now i think
we're gonna get into the the demo part
of this aren't we
um yeah let's do this
i'm gonna unplug my uh
my camera all right you guys hang tight
for a second
we're gonna do something oh sorry yeah
we have we actually have
like a video first okay okay
um you get to see my my mess
you wouldn't be a true artist if there
wasn't a mess yeah
okay okay
don't say that too loud okay all right
so this is the brief basically that i
came up with for myself
because uh because why not you know it's
it's always easier when you have a brief
so um um yeah i'm gonna do like a
t-shirt or like
poster mm-hmm i'm gonna
include you guys like the future with a
reference
with your hat which i was really happy
to see you came with with the right
made the right choice guys i made the
right choice very good
um i'm also gonna represent you know the
fact that i
uh you know you that the channel really
helped me to become a better freelancer
i'm gonna try and use the brand colors
of the future and of course i'm gonna
have some fun so i'm gonna draw a skull
excellent i already like this i love
where this is going
i can't wait to see you do this yes so
the first part is recorded because
it's just gonna take super long if if
we're gonna do everything live so this
is just like 10 minutes of
uh the the initial process uh
and yeah as you can see like i just i'm
just doing very
very freely and trying to come up with
ideas
at this point just keeping it loose and
working fast right
yeah yeah like very small dude and now
it's like the
i did a few of those and this is like
the final uh
doodle i guess which is a bit more uh
it took a longer i guess it's bigger i
also now have realized you're
left-handed
so tell me what you're thinking about
when you're drawing here are you looking
at anything or you're just kind of
working out the composition
yeah i'm looking at skulls and
i'm trying to come up with an
interesting
composition but i i've made a lot of
changes like later in photoshop so
uh yeah this sketch is is not that great
but uh
maybe it's it's kind of like my process
start with a very bad sketch
is this fairly typical for your process
on paper first
draw draw ideas okay and then you'll
scan it in
oh no i'm just uh i'm taking a picture
with my phone i see
okay that works yeah so
yeah i thought like yeah i'm gonna draw
a skull
which is kind of like i don't know like
a
portrait of mine which i like to do
and i'm gonna use the hat and
add some more like elements so the
future's had like your hat basically
with the with the text
and then do my own take on it sort of
so so the hat's floating a little bit
above the head right
yeah cool yeah and this pose of the hat
didn't work okay i tried a few
but i thought
i thought it would be interesting yeah a
little play button for
youtube you know nice
those are what we call like uh what do
they call those things jonah easter eggs
oh yeah yeah where you kind of look into
it later you're like oh i saw another
thing hidden in there that's a cool
reference just like
the log with the record i didn't notice
exactly before
yeah because you're talking that's like
it's nice
totally yeah that's like my favorite
thing to do
so instead of crossbones here is that a
pencil that you're gonna be
putting through the head nice oh yeah
okay
now do you listen to music when you work
or is just silence uh tell me a little
bit about what is happening i have to
yeah i i have to have some music playing
to give me some momentum yeah
it's funny how that works but it's it's
it's like magic
so okay so i
here i thought like maybe there's a line
coming out of the pencil and
and then i'll it will go across
the the designer
the word designer and it's gonna it's
gonna write illustrator instead
um you will see it later in the process
okay so we're now in photoshop right
yeah you scanned it in or you took a
picture and now you're working through
the problem
making sure that things are symmetrical
and kind of the way they
that you like okay uh-huh i see what
you're doing here
yeah i always have like guidelines
mm-hmm to make sure things are
precise and pierced so yeah
so yeah sorry do you always include or
have like
things to include in your illustrations
like the god as a designer hat
the brand colors do you always give
yourself like these kind of constraints
or things to incorporate i think
i'll try to at least i mean uh it's
actually easier than just
uh when a client say like do whatever
you want that's like the hardest thing
yeah
right right i mean uh you actually had a
post about it like
recently you know yes yeah yeah
you know here's the weird thing a lot of
young people especially who
who don't know this because they've been
working with horrible clients or bosses
that just
micromanage everything they think the
dream is to have an open brief like do
whatever you want
it's not true exactly exactly because
that means everything can work
and that's going to be really tough
because you sit there jonah
like i like to work within constraints
because then i can pull my creativity
and sometimes the constraint is a budget
or a timeline
or to use a specific logo that you hate
and you get really inventive about
it exactly so now like
i'm i'm relaxed and i don't need to
think about the colors because the
colors are given
so for me it's actually easier even if
these are not
colors i'll ever use like your blue and
yellow are uh a bit crazy for me yeah
it's actually interesting and uh yeah
i'm interested to see like what's gonna
happen
using these colors now you do like to
use really bright brilliant colors too
but just usually just one color right
like a
brilliant blue or a hot pink magenta or
something like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah
not more than like two or three colors i
guess
most of the time mm-hmm and
i think you told us before that you were
using a wacom tablet
yeah yeah i use a welcome tablet and by
the way this took me
something like an hour okay good to know
yeah it looks like it's really fast
right now but uh it's
something like an hour yeah and if
you've seen any of pierre's work you'll
notice that he reworks stuff all the
time
like me i'm like i get attached to my
own drawing i'm like that's that's good
and i don't go back you can see he's
reshaping things all the time
like okay the jaw or the what is that
called yeah
yeah she's making it taller shorter
rounder sharper just
tweaking it until it feels right yeah
yeah so it looks fast
as if i'm really like i'm very sure at
what i'm doing but i actually have no
idea
i'm just testing stuff and i try to keep
things very
loose and yeah see what works
[Music]
i noticed you dropped the eyes down a
little bit there yeah
it kind of gives it a cooler look
because the forehead gets a little bit
bigger
and and the eyes kind of are drawn it
looks a little bit more menacing
exactly yeah yeah yeah a bit more angry
the the eyebrows i think
really helped like the the position of
the
eyebrows the arch there yeah and that
and then the eyebrows added in yeah
so i noticed that you you did this in
the sketch but there's this
this line that's circling around him and
i i think i know why you put that in
there just
because of you want to create this
organic shape to kind of
create this asymmetry in it but what is
that ultimately going to be
you mean the red line there's a line
going from the eye and it circles around
the back of the head and
goes out the other side or something
like that that that curve
yeah yeah so it is the it's the line
that is being drawn by the pencil
basically
oh i see oh i get it now yeah it's kind
of messy but
the point here is like the idea here is
that he's gonna
cross like cover the word designer and
it's gonna be written
instead it's gonna be written like god
is an illustrator
i like that okay okay so it's kind of
hard to understand
but uh i i think it's getting it will be
better like
as i keep working on it yeah
no it is it is and you know i'm really
glad that you're on our show
showing this because people ask all the
time like when can we see more
illustration stuff well just wait
just wait something's coming and here we
are so this is great
for all those people this is going to
have to hold you over for a little while
because i know we are very design
centric
here here we go yeah
and a bunch of lefties in in the
audience watching live just want to say
hello and they're like yeah lefties do
it better
sure thing
totally
yes i'm switching to real text now
because uh
it's gonna be easier to understand
what's happening
yeah and i changed the position of like
the word illustrator also to be
on top of the hat later on
that came to you a little bit later or
it did
i wasn't sure like what's where to place
it but it felt
right yeah just next to the text
it's gonna be easier to read it's uh
yeah it looks like a mess right now but
my buddy angel acevedo who's the the the
guy behind the hat the goddess of
designer hat he's on watching right now
he's like
it's dope to see other people's process
most definitely
ah that's so cool
[Music]
okay that's better already
and it's so violently crossed out there
okay
well it's a self-portrait so
yeah i thought it would it would be
interesting to i mean i
at first i thought maybe i should do
like uh god is a designer
and illustrator but then i thought it's
funnier if the designer is crossed over
wait a minute you just dropped in a new
pencil
yeah i just find found one on google
images
and this one's in perspective right like
it's
exactly yeah i'm not that good at
drawing in perspective
so i guess i i did the lazy thing here
or the smart thing yeah
but uh yeah
just a shortcut but yeah i use
references all the time i mean i'm not
ashamed of it i mean that's totally fine
and everybody does
and that's totally okay as long as you
don't you know totally rip off
somebody's
else work yeah this is just like a very
small element
right it's reference man yeah exactly
so there's a comment here from dwlz i
believe that's or dwi
i can't read that but it says not a
lefty but even with my right eye
suck ha ha and he says tendon and nerve
damage yay sorry to hear that
um it doesn't really matter if you're
left or right handed it just
it's interesting sometimes because
lefties are
a little less or a little bit more rare
in the world right
yeah and i think we actually live uh
less time
really on average yeah that sucks wow
so uh we have to make it count i guess
yes you do
[Laughter]
yes a little bit of money like uh dollar
bills
around and a subscribe button of course
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
this is a great opportunity right
plug in so yes we'll make sure we
include the link to your channel
because pierre does also have a youtube
channel guys so don't forget
and don't forget to like comment
subscribe and hit the bell notifications
on both our channels but we'll make sure
we have the link in the show notes
that's awesome there we go it's starting
to come together now
okay so how much time has elapsed in
real time right now
um yes like just a little bit over an
hour okay
um and we're almost done i just like
just blocked in some colors to see
uh what it feels like um
i can already see like it's it's
interesting how you know when you come
back to a drawing
after you sleep on it i can already see
like i'm gonna change the back
to a darker color like the darker blue
but
uh yeah just sometimes you have to kind
of uh
sleep on it and uh until you find a
better solution so
i think this is like the end of the
process yeah okay this is like
what i came up with until now okay
ooh it's exciting now okay are we going
live now are you going to be working on
this live with us
yep all right here comes this this does
not happen that often on our channel so
i'm really excited to see this okay so
now we're in photoshop
on a pc with a wacom tablet and the
reason why we can't
uh see pierrot right now is we're out of
ports or channels or whatever
guys so you'll have to like look at my
ugly face while he's running okay
yeah i think my computer can't handle it
anyway so
it's actually better at least okay okay
all right
um yeah so i think the darker color will
work better here
and now you see that i'm actually super
slow
when i work and yeah in real time okay
so using the lasso tool there it's not
that exciting i guess seeing that
the real speed here so yeah i'm going to
use like a darker tint
and then okay i don't know it just makes
sense to me
okay hopefully um and now this is just
like a mess
so i'm gonna do i'm just gonna
lower the opacity here can you see my
layers panel yes we can okay awesome
so and i'm just gonna work with my pen
tool
i'm gonna recreate it oh interesting now
now you're gonna get really precise huh
yeah okay so you're using the pen tool
with uh shapes right
yeah exactly that way you can adjust it
and you can get really clean lines
all right guys this is where the magic
happens
it's not in the bedroom it's right here
you're gonna get to see this
very slow magic but yeah
and you're probably making a little like
little decisions here and there to kind
of refine the line the curve and the
sharpness of the angles right
yeah i already saw that i like uh i
don't know the size of the skull felt
right even though like the
the line is actually here like a bit
taller i think
i think this this works so i'm just
gonna do this
and i'm gonna duplicate
and flip and yep
that's it there we go see yeah we're
good
yep this is where all the graphic design
skills come into play here
yeah so
okay now for the hat
now let's keep working on this one so
yeah the eyes as well
so will you be doing a hybrid of
illustrator like
clean vector and photoshop painted
things or will
just be very clean vector the whole time
no i'm going to use like
as always i'm going to use my brush my
one and only
brush later on okay add some
textures and like shadows and stuff now
when you say your one and only brush
it's because you're just using default
brushes
most of the time yeah i just use like a
simple
line brush for just like very clean and
simple lines like this one and i have
a grainy brush that does
this thing basically these very small
dots
oh yeah they are tiny yep that's all i
use basically i see
and that's a brush you made of just like
a bunch of little dots
i didn't make it it's actually it comes
free with your photoshop you just need
to
find it it's it's all brush so it's in
the
legacy folder of the of the all brushes
yeah so yeah that's what i like to use
basically so pretty much you all have
the exact same tools pierre has there's
no
no secret brush there's no i'm a simple
guy
he's a simple guy and he's doing this
work so you really have no excuse
everybody except for the skill
other than that we're all the same
but that's good to know yeah
i think yeah i bet you you could just
create a couple of line brushes and a
couple of stippling brushes and
sell it as a kit oh my god yeah you're
so right i'm i'm
i think you need to take you know yeah
i'm making a mistake that i'm using just
just free brushes
the pure custom signature brush
yeah exactly
yeah you should do that and then sell
them for not a lot of money and then
every day people will be buying you
lunch based on the purchases they make
oh my god if i had like one dollar for
every comment on
youtube and instagram about the brushes
that's what you need to do man
totally
so how does how the spin i mean is this
it's perfect
no i i want to see it in this speed
because when people speed it up
those time lapse things they're very
hard to figure out sometimes like what
you're working
through right so right now when you see
like a really awesome skull
and the way that you drew the eyes of
the nose that's really cool so i can't
wait to kind of keep seeing like where
this evolves into
you guys we're doing this live so
welcome all 424 people watching now live
with us
thanks for tuning in guys and i see that
the audience has slowly grown over time
initially we started out with a little
bit more than 100 so
we're getting to the juicy the juicy
stuff here guys so hang in there some
people are tuning in quite late so
they're like sleepy but i'm gonna make
it through this
it's really nice
so yeah i'm gonna do the hat now nylish
is making fun of me chris
with his business mind lol
well this is a popular thing like when
you're a known artist
illustrator people want to use the tools
that you use so
it makes a lot of sense right
look at this guys let's just do a little
business basics here while
while pierre is working here michael
jordan
the nike shoe the the famous one the
retro one that
everybody is like coveting and bought i
was watching the last dance and i think
they
they had a very modest goal for the
first year and they blew that out like
by a crazy factor
and why is that why did everybody want
to buy this shoe because you want to get
this much closer to being like michael
jordan
that's what it's about because you feel
connected to michael and his greatness
uh his his majesty the air supreme
by wearing the same shoe or wearing the
same jersey
see so that's why it's like we want to
be connected to you even though we know
in our mind we know we're not going to
play basketball like that i'm not going
to be able to
to dunk or float through the air i'm not
going to be able to draw like pierre
but i'm just a little bit closer it
makes me feel
you know like you're you're sort of
within reach sort of out of reach
but that's the idea wanted to be like
mike mm-hmm
so this one is but you know i wish like
people would ask me more about
like how how did i actually practice
okay so let's let's talk about that how
did you practice
i mean i think a lot of people uh like
just think about those those technical
stuff yeah instead of actually focusing
on
on like how do they practice because
that's
that's the only like relevant question
that can help them i think
and how do they how do i practice um
that's
i think i can break it down into like uh
two things basically
it's really hard but as as i'm working
on this hat
to think and speak i'm sorry it's okay
i was trying to feel the the air so that
you can focus i know how hard it is
because you know everybody's watching
you every every mouth click they're
looking at it's like oh
totally yeah i just need to figure out
this hat okay
yeah i've been i've enjoyed like three
times
in the first uh like video that we saw
earlier
i don't know if you know this like a
child yeah i saw it
right first it was front-facing you you
drew one profile in the
very early sketch really exaggerated
yeah brim
i'll tell you what i can work as a model
for you me
jonah yeah he's your photo
i got it right here man there you go
i'll do the other side
this one yeah perfect
yeah uh fashion luxury brands um anybody
this this face is for rent you guys can
you can hire me as a model
okay yeah the drawing the hat the shape
and the brim and getting the right
dimensionality out of it it is tricky
i've drawn a few hats my day
yeah that's it's funny they don't really
look like anything i don't know
yeah not my thing to draw i definitely
wouldn't draw a hat
it wasn't such like a big reference
that i kind of felt like i have to use
now if you think of the hat really as a
plane
and with a cylinder it starts to make a
little bit more sense because this is a
flat brim hat
and it's a little easier to draw than
the baseball style ones which
are curved which is basically a
quarter cylinder or a flat plane
that is then just droopy right so
um hey jonah why don't we do this well
can you grab me a marker within a like a
white piece of paper i'm going to try to
see if i can explain something here
yeah so why don't we park it on this
screen here
well we can watch pierre work and me
talking and jonah getting me a marker
okay cool thanks man
all right
all right we're getting there i guess
that's better
henrik is asking please start teaching i
believe you already
are and and you need to just check him
out on his different channels
on instagram and especially on youtube
where you can see the longer videos
yeah i mean it's not really teaching but
i mean i have been thinking about it
[Music]
yeah definitely yeah i need to do like a
course or something
and jonas here to the rescue thank you
jonah all right we got something in here
for sure
and while you're drawing i will draw two
jonah these are um
unfortunately dry erase markers all of
these are
well no those are and they're gonna
smear all over place let's see
metallic color pen okay let me try and
work with this one
all right is it working yeah i'll try
and get this one to work
all right so you're using an ellipse
there to kind of figure out the end cap
or the eraser head yeah
this does seem like for more complicated
illustration
this is a pretty long process right
yeah i mean uh yeah it takes time you
know it's a few hours of work
most of the time just a few not not like
a couple of days worth of work
yeah i mean it really depends on on the
illustration but yeah it can take like
days um yeah it's funny because i always
look at the recording
and then it's it seems shorter but
actually
i recorded just like the parts where i
actually work on it but sometimes they
just sit and stare at the illustration
and think about it so i guess it's
longer actually
most of the time
okay what's the longest you've ever
worked on a piece
i think i don't know like 20 hours
something like that
that's not bad i mean it's not
like super long no
it's reasonable yeah i think so
okay the pencil
is getting there
are you drawing chris i am what am i
missing oh i'm missing all the
well i'm gonna show people actually can
we see this jana am i in the right spot
there
so i wanted to show you this simple
geometry of this right
so if you look at the top of the hat
it's basically a cylinder with a rounded
edge in the top
and what i learned in school i studied
graphic design as well but i did take
the life drawing and and
industrial design sketching classes they
called it viscom and so if you're able
to break things down into the simple
shapes a cylinder
a square a sphere a cone a pyramid
then things become a lot easier right so
the first one that i drew and i added
some cut lines in there so you guys can
see it
and i'm going to work on the bottom here
and i'm going to show you how to
draw the cap when it's from underneath
like this
okay so the first one is like we're
looking down at it i hope that was clear
jonah can we see this or is it yeah okay
and then i'll work on the bottom one
i'll be right back okay
so what are you doing here pierre so
yeah i'm just working on the eraser part
seems kinda seems like it's
looks something like that i'm not sure
but oh
yeah i'm just going to go back i'm not
sure man as soon as you have that
stippling it just
goes to another level it really does
that's the secret thing yeah
maybe this part is a bit smaller yeah
i don't know
seems fine let's do the bottom part now
and so
man that's tough like a penciling
perspective and a hat
which i never drew before definitely
out of my comfort zone here
living on the edge yeah let me see
what's going on here did i mess up my
appointment
no i don't think so now your podcast is
that three
yeah but i just got a skype message from
him
and i always panic you know like oh my
god i screwed up double booked
no we're still okay all right now i want
to show you guys the hat
the next version of this and i'm going
to shade it in a little bit so that you
guys can see a little bit better
okay so here you see i drew the cylinder
but this time i was looking at it from
the bottom
so this part should be right so this is
the plane
i'm sorry i'm like trying to coordinate
myself backwards here
so there it is that's a plane and then i
just round off the corners and it's
going to look like a hat as soon as i
start adding shading
and then i'll do a version without all
the construction lines so it's a little
bit easier for you to see and i'll
even drop in a skull or my my lame
version of a skull
so we're drawing we're learning together
all right
okay
i'm starting to like these uh colors
they grow on you i guess it's kind of
like the ikea colors
if you really think about it
yeah my next sponsor
hopefully yeah after seeing this
okay the pencil is fine
oh i need this uh
the scope
what's up
let's see jonah are there any questions
in here oh let me go through
i was getting mesmerized by the
[Laughter]
oh i did i don't want to touch on that
topic that that yeah
left um how he got into designing like
how that's
more important than the actual tool yeah
did you want to talk about that pierre
sorry i didn't hear you very well
what do you say earlier you had
mentioned how people ask you
like what kind of tools you're using and
how they
oh yeah yeah yeah how to practice yeah
how to practice there we go yeah
so yeah i think um i think
there's two things you should do if you
want to get better at illustration and
and maybe like i don't know maybe people
are not speaking about it
that often but um so usually
you know if you ask about it people will
tell you to do like studies from real
life
which are super important but i think
it's just like half of
of what you need to practice um
and i think it's actually really
important to study also
uh just drawings of other illustrators
and artists
that you like and try to break down like
how they did a certain illustration and
again it's almost like coping but
uh as long as it's for studying i think
it's it's actually really important
i'm pretty sure like the like
renaissance artists and all these
uh you know people from artists from the
past actually did is quite a lot
um but nowadays i don't know it's kind
of one of these things nobody speaks
about
um so i think you know
it's actually good to do kind of you
know study both
you know both from real life and from uh
from other artists and
also i mean i try to to break it down
to um you know sometimes i just practice
line work like sketching with a pencil
in my sketchbook
and sometimes i'll do like color
breakdowns when i actually
try to finalize a piece using photoshop
or whatever
software program you use so um
yeah that's pretty i mean that's kind of
general but that's that's i think what
you need to do if you want to
just improve fast yeah a friend of mine
who
some of you guys may know his name is
ash thorpe and he told me when he was
learning how to draw
one of his instructors would say if you
suck at hands
draw 100 hands if you suck at feet draw
100 feet and just do it over and over
and over and just keep learning
and eventually by the 99th hand you're
going to get good at it you're going to
start to understand things but
here we go i'm not saying on pierre but
uh let's see if you can see it oh
wow i see it really small on my screen
right can you guys see that so i tried
to draw the skull kind of the way he did
and we're looking up at the hat
i realize right now that the hat is
pointed so far up
that it's going to be impossible to see
the the god is a designer text so
i'm going to make an edit on this and
i'll show you back i'll show you
my update in a little bit okay
nice
so uh rivalda is giving you a lot of
support in the chat she's like it's
probably very difficult for you to
answer questions while doing the
illustrations
she's like in all caps you can do it
pierre keep going with a muscle like
boom
you can do it very strong
ah that's awesome thanks so much
someone asked well and you kind of
touched this on this already uh any tips
for a self-taught designer for
improvement
any tips like in what topic i don't know
it's kind of general
let me ask them again
tips
yeah i guess just to get better at
illustration
i think he already said it to practice
to not only study
from real life yeah anymore yeah i also
um i mean i think that a lot of people
are very
interested in like finding their style
as an illustrator
it's something i also get a lot of
questions about
you know how do you develop your style
but i mean i think it's it's the most
important thing is to actually
understand
you know what type of illustration you
actually like
doing and you know what are other
artists that you actually
admire and i mean once you know that
you have like a direction that you
actually can aim for
um in terms of like what kind of you
know technique you need to
develop and
so so i guess the the first thing i mean
i
i like this uh i don't remember like
who's
who spoke about it but uh uh
what's his name like the chef uh gordon
ramsay
um so i think somebody asked him about
like uh
what's uh the best tip for like well
what's the most important skill for a
chef
and um the answer he
he was he was saying is you know you
have to have a
good taste so
and that's so true i mean what what's
your taste what
the the type of illustration you
actually like is the most important
thing
and that's like the first step and i
realized like when i answer stuff and
talk to you i'm just
automatically stop and i don't draw so
sorry about that
i'm just moving the screen like and
that's it yeah so why don't we do this
guys let's give
pierre a chance to keep drawing here so
we understand how hard it is to draw to
concentrate
and uh let's minimize the questions here
so you guys maybe you can it's okay
okay okay if you want you can have some
other kind of question maybe joan and i
can help you with those
okay yeah this one's an easy one who are
some artists that inspire you
oh yeah so i think
um i mean when i was uh still studying i
was
at the final year at the university and
i
i started i got the opportunity to work
in a
screen printing workshop
that we had in the university
and then you know as i was starting to
work there on my
prints i discovered some of my
favorite artists i mean until today i
mean
um so definitely drew middleward
and macbeth and yeah studio
all these guys make amazing
illustrations and they use
a lot of screen printing so
and because of that because it's like a
limited media
media that you you have to print each
color in a separate uh
screen so uh it's you don't use a lot of
colors
because it's uh it's too much work so
i guess you know i started looking at
the work and saw that they don't use a
lot of colors and this is why i started
to limit my
color palette as well even though i
don't
print that much of my work um
so i guess yeah these artists definitely
like inspired me and
uh helped me understand you know what
what type of
illustrations i want to start doing
so yeah drew milward is amazing
and yeah studio
and macbeth definitely
okay that's nice and shiny
nice
yeah that works now on this one are you
planning to use any black
any line work or is it just shapes and
shading
uh yeah i'll usually just work with
shapes and
lose most of the line work i think i'm
not yeah i'm not sure what it's called
but
i mean if i can lose the line i'll
definitely lose it as a general
rule my work process
sorry jonah i'm i'm actually responding
to jeff who i'm supposed to be doing a
podcast with
there's some confusion in time so guys i
normally don't do that but uh
when you're when your phone's blowing up
when somebody's expecting you to be on a
call
i have to attend to that so we're
probably gonna have to
we're gonna keep going here for sure
oh yeah i got the time mixed up
something he's in a different time zone
that happens a lot
so
all right let's get back to the show
here let's see
okay here's a question i can handle this
from jacob chris with many exclamation
points
how do you respond when you you present
a project to your client and they say
that's easy i could have done that um
that's a that's a tough one to respond
to and i think
when you hear somebody say that it's
kind of disheartening it could
kind of feel like a punch in the gut
because it's not easy and even if it
worries it
it's easy for you because you've put in
the time in the practice but
probably for in my world that doesn't
happen that often because we do actually
build very complicated things but i
usually would then respond
sometimes what what is what looks simple
and it's easy
it's actually harder to do that because
you have to show a lot of
restraint in designing things and so we
tried lots of things
and ultimately through the process of
elimination we're able to come up with
this thing
right like if you look at almost every
big brand that's out there
it almost looks like as if someone could
just type it in on a computer and say
we're done
i remember there was a bid on jimmy
kimmel he was giving the
the design team at wolf olins owen
something like that the ones who
designed the
uber logo he said so six months later uh
this is what they came up with and they
spent three hundred thousand dollars do
that
isn't that just you typing in as a font
well that that's an easy joke to have
and we can all laugh and designers and
creatives can laugh at that but
what you don't realize is they go
through so many studies and ideation
that they
all kind of come to this point of
clarity and then they
make something very simple and if you
look around in the world you'll notice
that some of the biggest
most valuable brands in the world
they have this kind of confidence where
they don't have to add too much
like you look at the nike logo with the
swoosh and in the
futura bold condensed typeface
oblique it's very simple and you'll
notice almost always that the mom and
pop shops have
35 layers of things 14 different
typefaces
it's because they think that's what good
design is just add lots of stuff to it
and here is the point of contrast for
you and i i'm going to sound like an
apple fanboy
and i don't care if you think that it's
probably true anyways but
when you go inside an apple store
arguably one of the most successful
retail experiences from
how much they sell per square foot and
this is a thing that you can look up
and you look at it it's wide open
beautiful light
simple materials and if you count the
number of materials you're going to see
like okay
there's a lot of restraint here and it
creates a feeling of
a premium experience it feels very
upscale and high-end
helping them to justify the price of the
computers that they're selling to you
now conversely and since i've traveled a
little bit and one of my favorite places
to go
is taiwan my wife is from there i'll
walk in
to a computer department store or
something like that and it's the exact
opposite experience they literally have
signs
hanging all over every display the boxes
are littered with typography
price points and deals and each one is
its own
uh island screaming for attention
and then here my mind is like i want to
pay as little as possible
they're they're giving me this flea
market
swap meet vibe this used car salesman
vibe
and that's where they're not confident
they're trying to pitch and sell you all
the time
let's switch examples then here's
another example in in real life
you'll see in a room full of people
maybe it's
at a gathering some kind of function
that you're going to in your networking
and then there's a person let's just
there there's a
there's a guy standing there it's really
well dressed
not too flashy everything is just really
understated and everything is right
place but it's not screaming
and then there's another guy's walking
in with a bright turquoise blue suit
with zebra print on it with crocodile
loafers pointed shoes and a big open
collar and this
poof of hair that's walking around like
with gold and an eyeliner and makeup
you think okay and you know different
strokes were different folks
no judgment there on the person but it's
like which one's more confident
which one would you rather spend more
time with which one do you think is more
successful just by that description
now of course we know that people in
entertainment especially
dress in very flamboyant ways it's ways
to get attention they're very
they're they're what's called like
peacocking like hey everybody look at me
but you may want to spend more time
hanging out getting to know the person
who's quiet who's understated who's
reserved who's poised and
has a very classic look there's a time
and place for both so in case i come in
one day with makeup and a big hairdo and
a bright turquoise jacket it's a
different vibe
but that's what i'm talking about so
people often will mistake
complexity with labor and the harder you
work on something
the more valuable it should be
it's actually the opposite okay let's
check in with pierre like how are we
doing now
i think it's uh it's going nicely yeah
so the play button is glowing right it's
it's internally illuminated it's out the
idea
yeah exactly i added some
just some stippling dots here
um the pencil seems nice
i guess i'm gonna fix the line that goes
on top
of that text i'm going to just use
the pen tool this time okay i noticed
something and i want to ask you a
question when you're stippling
in some of the highlights in the shadows
do you first create a shape with your
lasso tool and then you paint in it like
a stencil
a mask yeah sometimes yeah
um yeah definitely helps when i need to
have
let's say one of the edges should be
like um
you know sharp sometimes you need like a
sharp edge sometimes
you need to be like gradient so um
yeah very good
i love how you drew the bottom chin jaw
thing it's very cute it's got a lot of
style to it
right and i think this is where i get to
see
you injecting your pov into it because i
would have drawn a more realistic jaw
but something like this yeah yeah yeah
so this
the skull that you drew has really angry
eyes
and the skull inherently is not very
friendly but the way you do that lower
jaw it's like yeah
it's all right it's a little fun it's
fun yeah
i mean yeah i mean definitely i guess
that that's like my
personality and like my my own personal
taste
and i mean i never do like really
hardcore
like gory stuff in my illustrations
right damn the pencil looks good
[Laughter]
with all the shading and the shadow
there john are you getting seduced by
the stippling oh
geez yeah jonah's gonna forget that he's
editing this too
he's gonna be stuck on looking at you
work there and i wouldn't blame them
i like you playing in opposites like
this the contrast
of a scary menacing skull but the way
that's rendered is very simple and
graphic
and the teeth aren't sharp they're kind
of rounded and they're
it's like the most friendly zombie
you've ever seen
yeah exactly yeah i love cartoons
and that's like a major influence
on my style and my work and
yeah that's like my personality is yeah
i'm just not that
i'm scary nice dude now do you
do you decorate your studio apartment or
wherever you're at
with cute things too um
i have like a lot of posters here on the
wall and some
i don't know like
like dolls and stuff but not not too
crazy
mostly like posters and prints from
friends
i should send you some uh posters i
would love that if you did
now i think also your style is
so marketable and i like you said
the brief was to design a t-shirt or
poster and i can see this working on
a lunchbox i could see this on a thermos
i can see this
as a sticker or a print on a shot glass
and i think the reason why it's so
marketable is you can appeal to both men
and women
right because the skull is usually like
oh i'm a tough guy
skull's a pirate rebel and then this
the kind of soft teeth and the bone jaw
that you did at the bottom with rounded
teeth too it's like oh it's kind of cute
i like that
so i can see uh women getting into this
and and wearing a shirt or
maybe a pattern or a print i think it's
really cool
oh my god i'm so happy you said it and
it's recorded
i don't know if my wife is watching
right now but she is always
she's like oh again with the skulls is
she rolling her eyes and she says that
yeah
and
so yeah i'm happy you know you think
that it's it's relatable for women as
well and
i can see like in in the comments and
like on instagram and stuff that
uh yeah i mean that's that's actually
true and
uh you know actually dividing the crowd
into like
male and female and all that stuff it's
kind of old
anyway it's like
[Music]
not that relevant i guess nowadays
now you you drew a pen stroke and
how did you make it all ragged like that
the uh what do you mean the pen stroke
like it's it's not smooth right it's got
texture to it on the edges
this one the the yellow yeah the yellow
line that's circling around everything
oh no i think it's just like the layer
uh oh i see i see okay i got it
the original layer yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna use it
whenever you see those circles i'm just
selecting areas and i'm just deleting
the
sketch and cleaning my illustrations so
yeah as i told you before i'm trying to
slowly just get rid of
all the lines and stay with mostly like
just
shapes simple shapes okay so i'm gonna
ask you a business question
in case somebody's watching this who
who's thinking themselves yeah i
i think i need to hire peer how do you
structure your fees are there some
general guidelines you can give us in
case somebody's thinking you know i need
that
i need you to design something for our
studio our company
our event something like that how do you
structure fees
um it really depends on i think a few
things like you know
first of all like the size of the
company okay um
the type of illustration and
especially like the number of sketches
like different schedules i'll usually
try to come up with at least like two or
three different sketches
um and that's actually the hardest part
you know actually coming up with
with new ideas so that would definitely
like
affect the price um
and then yeah it really depends on
like what's what's the illustration like
what actually do i need to draw and
you know the size of the of the client
the size of the company
yeah do you have like a ballpark figure
like from
like if somebody i don't know like i say
design studios like you know what we
would love for you to do something for
us and they're not a giant corporation
it's not
like they're going to slap it on a
million t-shirts or something is that a
ballpark
yeah i mean i think like it's pretty
wide but i would say
from a thousand to five thousand uh
dollars
uh it's well it's a pretty big range but
yeah
uh but that's helpful yeah yeah
something like that and
you know sometimes i'll take like very
small like uh
private commissions and then i might
even do something for
uh for less but you know
just for like private people who need
like i don't know like a tattoo or
something like that
oh that would be cool yeah you know it
happens uh here and there and
uh like i'm i'm okay with adjusting my
price
for like smaller like super small
companies and like
personal clients as long as they can you
know can have
the time to work on it and i'm not like
super busy i see
that's good to know so companies brands
studios designers
people who want to collaborate with you
uh pierre to
you know if it's a smaller-ish thing
prices start at about 5k
guys so that's kind of the benchmark
there if you have at least 5k at least
you know reach out to him after the show
yeah exactly thanks for that yeah
that's good
it's almost like as if i teach people
how to price right and talk about money
it's almost as if so yeah and um no i
think i mean i
i really enjoy you know seeing your
videos and you know
the way you approach like pricing and
working with clients and all that stuff
i think it it came to me like you know
when i just got started as an
illustrator uh i mean i
don't remember like how long do you guys
actually
make videos but uh
yeah i mean you started like three or
like four years ago right
at least yes the future started about
three or four years ago i think four
years but
yeah i started making videos in 2014 but
not as the future
right okay so yeah i mean i just got
started basically
freelancing and i had zero idea like
what i'm doing and
i mean these videos really helped me so
excellent good to hear so yeah i'm just
going to draw the dollar bills now
all right perfect timings talking about
money perfect transition there
all right while we're talking about that
i i can't
uh how do i pronounce this person's name
here i'm gonna i'm not gonna
pronounce the person name but she's
asking
is it still worth it to pursue
illustration as a career
like practically speaking especially for
beginners illustration is getting more
commodified with flat monthly fee
services as an example what are your
thoughts on that
oh man that's really interesting um
but i think you can say the same thing
on like graphic design
yes you can and like even like
ux stuff like there's like a lot of like
ai
that starts to develop and you know
start to
uh get into the market of even like ux
design and i think as long as you're
doing like a
good job and you find a niche and you're
good at what you're doing i guess
that makes sense and that can work
right i mean i need a reference for this
dollar
dollar bill okay while pierre's looking
for some reference there
i think the way you have to look at like
this is as the market gets
more crowded and more people are doing
it you have to then do something
that makes your work stand out
just by a little bit and i think i've
tried my best to point out some of the
things that makes pierre's work so
intriguing
because there's no shortage of artists
and illustrators out on the internet
especially if you go on places like
behance or instagram there's a ton of
people doing really cool work
but the ones that stand out they've got
a little edge of style
he shared a couple of tips with you his
number one tip was use local references
and
he was mixing his love for japanese
woodblock prince
with his his jewish culture living in
israel
and putting those two together and
finding that interesting combination
where the two
fit and he's taking things that i think
are typically seen as like real tough
guy kind of things and then
adding a little cuteness to it rounding
out some things and changing the
proportions
and i think that's what makes his work
stand out
so this room if you're willing to stand
out from the crowd
so if you wind up doing what everybody
else is doing no
you're going to be commodified in
just lowest price wins yeah
exactly but i also think it's a
wonderful time to to be alive and to
exist as a
image maker because the barriers to you
creating your own success and fame
are almost non-existent the internet has
squashed
and crushed all those gatekeepers to the
galleries and saying this is worth
it being art look what's happened with
banksy's career
and i have a friend i can't tell you um
his
his real name because he goes by the
name cryptic
and he does calligraphy as abstract
patterns
and that's all he does now he doesn't
work as a
hired gun anymore he does art and it's
really cool to see his work
so it's just like flat edge kind of
brush work and he's very good at it
his name is cryptic and he puts work out
there i have another friend
who who used to freelance for us from
time to time his name is chris saunders
and he does big murals now and and
that's really cool
i don't think that would have been able
to exist just
10 15 years ago prior to the the way
that social media is giving artists and
illustrators
exposure and the lines between being a
commercial illustrator and an artist
are blurring and you could you can move
between the two worlds if you
if you plan your career correctly so
there it is pros and cons
yeah this one works
yeah it feels funny working on such a
small detail but
i need a circle right
i see so here's the follow-up question
or statement
and and she's saying chris ironically
i'm applying to a company offering flat
money fees for illustration services
she's from the philippines look here's
the thing i think you need to do
something to make
money so that you can survive and pay
rent and take care of
yourself and then any of the loved ones
that you care to take
uh to take care of so here's the thing
once you get beyond that of your basic
survival needs
i think you have to start working on
your side hustle and i hate to say it i
know people don't like that term
but you got to start building up your
own name your own style and your own
reputation
otherwise you're going to be seen as a
gear a cog in the machine
and i hate i hate that that situation
exists but there's not much that i can
personally do about it so what you do is
you buy your time
you you go to work you do what they tell
you the corporate masters
and you just do that all you can eat
style of illustration
and then on the on the meantime you
start working on your own style and
growing an audience that shows up for
you because you're consistently giving
value
you're making people happy with the work
that you do and eventually you'll be
able to move
off the corporate job and
do your own thing and be be the
author to your own destiny
yeah totally
[Laughter]
oh jonah i think you read the same note
i just read
your wife is watching right now oh
yeah her name is ophir yep that's her
so hi how's it going uh thank you for
for allowing us to borrow pr for a
little bit and she's like
this is pierre's wife glad he's now
drawing dollar bills a skull
and a kissy face
good that's good that's that means that
she she heard
what you said about the the cute skull
so i'm good yes but also
you know if you guys i i'm offering this
only to you obviously but
if you ever need help in just
bouncing ideas off in terms of pricing
pierre feel free to call me now that we
have
some kind of communication open i'm more
than happy to help okay
awesome i mean
does this look like a dollar bill i'm
not sure but
it does
yeah i'm gonna work with that
yeah a few more all right it's gonna be
faster now yeah
i think i got it
so um chris what if i i'd love to pick
your brain like as i'm
drawing anyway okay um
i mean i'm i'm always like thinking
about like my
style and you know i mean i feel like
i'm pretty
uh i'm not that focused with my style i
guess
i wonder like what's what's your take on
that and
do you think i should focus and like
narrow down
um what do you think like is a strong
part of that like the thing that you
like most about about my work i guess
like i'd like to hear about that
okay uh i'm on somebody else's computer
right now otherwise i would pull up your
thing actually i have my phone handy
here
sorry guys i'm gonna just jump on
instagram and look up your work i feel
like you have a pretty strong style
and typically i would tell designers not
to have a strong style because it's
it's kind of boxing you in but for
illustrators and artists they need to
have
a pretty consistent look because when
they they own that category anybody that
wants to do anything like that they're
going to hire you
so you should corner this market right i
mean i think it's also relevant for
guys like i mean i remember you have
a live stream with the steve rabine for
example
and i mean i think i feel like he has
like a really great style
which totally works for him and i think
i mean
i think he focused and like the way he
did it
kind of worked for the best for him
i don't know what you think yeah so i'm
looking at your work here
and i i love the ones where you have
faces
and there's a kind of a retro vibe to
them their styling
or they've got that i guess some people
would call that hipster vibe
i like that you you bring in a little
bit of this punk and
and japanese aesthetic and i think
that's your sweet spot
i love the stippling and i love the
detailing that you do in some of your
drawings like this
wolf with his i think it's a wolf with a
three-eyed wolf and the fur and the
stippling
i think that's so cool
okay yeah i i would uh say that um some
of your work also includes this
like digital glitching kind of thing and
oh yeah
i i like that but i think that's pushing
you in a slightly different
space right i like i like the way that
you
you draw people and animals the
proportions they're they're kind of
they're not realistic like somebody some
hands or arms are really long
and i like the texture the the graphic
color blocking that you're doing
like this one with a dog lovers club
that looks a little bit outside your
style
yeah right they really worked well yeah
yeah
and i would just love to see more of
these the animals the birds and the
people and this kind of
cool hairdos that you have and how how
graphic the shapes are when you're
drawing
chris can you pull it up on that
computer i can't oh i can't
because uh i have to log into instagram
and i
don't have my password oh i'll log in
real quick oh you do it
all right jonah's going to help us
like i said before i think your style is
very marketable
and there's a there's a lot you can like
right now nobody's on our screen
let me jump back in sorry it's okay that
uh it's very marketable
and it could be used for music festivals
it could be used for merchandising
uh cool cool apparel and fashion i think
that could work really well
and if you keep doing that i i would not
be shocked if one of the big fashion
houses called you up and said hey we
want to do some kind of collab with you
that's that's interesting so
so yeah i mean i i do feel that i need
to maybe like
focus a little bit more and um
yeah it got me thinking like about the
direction i guess yeah like characters
is something that i really like to do
and i guess that's like
that's more interesting than other
things i do i guess
okay with jonah's help now we're on the
instagram page and i'll
now you guys can see this right so
there's
the information it's peer underscore
client house i i think at one point i
said it was a dash but it's actually
underscore
so my bad on that and you can probably
get all the relevant links to the things
he's doing here
now if you're a client and you want to
hire him or do a collaboration project
with him
his email is clienthouse.art gmail.com
and so when i look at this i think this
is really beautiful i think there's a
consistency here
amongst most of these pieces
now the one that stood out to me that
felt a little funky
is this one right here the dog lovers
club even the topography
and the way that the maybe it's just too
much color or something
this one um i don't know this is like a
famous character right
rick and morty yeah this one also feels
a little out of your
your style but the thing that i love
this this cat
it looks like the chester cat and this
this dog eating ramen noodles and
incorporating the japanese wood block
thing i think that's
very much in in your in your wheelhouse
and i think it's really really cool
i also love your use of patterns to
define
textiles and and cloth really cool
uh again there's the wolf another wolf
there and i love that
um this oh oh i didn't log in i forgot
my password too
how did you get past himself i just went
to his uh
instagram jonah so we're back to that
no nobody remembers their passwords
anymore okay so well
i i was gonna say like i really do enjoy
the digital glitchy things but
it does feel like it's another style on
top of a style
so that's that's just my two minutes i
love this woman here with a long neck
holding up the cup of coffee and the way
that you are
you render her fingers joe this is kind
of embarrassing with this giant thing
here like somebody save us
log into your account oh refresh it okay
let me refresh it
let's see what happens it'll go away
okay good
immediately okay let me let me get down
to that
spot there it's embarrassing
okay forget about it instagram security
is too good okay forget about this john
let's go back to uh
watching him work
okay oh i'm back
oh yes you are
close this what i haven't known
you haven't yeah all right come here
what's your password again i'm just
kidding
in case you want to hack him okay jonah
get over here
i'm gonna finish doing that while uh
pierre's finishing up but yeah
so how how are you doing on the on the
cap
do you think it's going to be kind of
like um
a more playful shape
what do you mean yeah like is this the
final rendering of the hat
well now that you're asking i mean
i didn't mean like no i'm just curious
[Music]
it's work in progress yeah i'm not sure
okay
yeah it's definitely tricky but uh
yeah i'm gonna work on the skull for now
this piece right here now we're back
with jonah's password
oh yeah i love that so like different
textures and
i i'm not sure if i watched this exact
one but i've seen you draw
animals like this when sometimes the
first round one way it's curved and
sometimes it's sharp and and
and all this this is really awesome it
also reminds me of certain kind of
like tattoo art and i think that's why
people are probably asking you to design
a tattoo for them
and yeah that's really cool like when
people start putting your art on their
body
you know you got something right totally
that's really cool yeah actually
really i really want to get into tattoos
and maybe
learn how to do it and do it like from
time to time
it looks like fun so this one is really
cool i love her extended long
neck and i love the patterns and the
striping and
this is just the work of a designer i
can't i can tell that that design is
part of your dna
right really good color blocking and i
could even see this being turned into
maybe tiles that they use in a like a
really upscale hotel
right just a strip of these right and
you could do that
because it's so graphic
yeah i'm i'm a sucker for this kind of
tattoo looking art
i really like it it just makes me feel
warm inside
i thought this this illustration that
you did was really cool too again
all the detail with the hair the shape
it's got a kind of a cool old-school
vibe
the the graphic blocking on the tongue
that the texture and the striping looks
really good
the way that you rendered her and her
look with the black lipstick
it's kind of retro can you zoom in on
the chris yeah
hopefully yeah i mean it's pretty
realistic i mean i use the photo
reference for the
woman and i'm not sure like if this is
like a good direction for me i'm still
kind of trying to figure this out
actually no i love it
i mean i could see this and i know
you've done some skateboards before
some one of the big skateboard companies
saying hey we want you to do a line of
eight boards for us
right yeah i'm actually working on three
new ones
you are right now yeah for for yourself
or for a company
no for a company in canada all right
yeah yeah that's kind words i mean yeah
you
you and skate culture uh certain kind of
fashion brands
totally in this place again i don't know
when you did this piece here
but let's take a look at it oops yeah i
mean it's not that
old yeah yeah but i like it just
the typography um and the kind of
rendering of the feathers
very geometric and it feels almost like
armor
as feathers it's pretty cool i love the
little detail the filigree and the
the the leaves and the botanical
references
and the patterning i know another guy um
uh uh mr uh i'm spacing on his name
right now a french guy
it'll come to me in a little bit but he
does all this kind of vintage retro
thing with design
do you sell your prints
yeah i mean um i had like an online shop
and then i changed it and yeah i just
reopened like
an online shop with some t-shirts um
yeah definitely something i need to
develop more
yeah totally like this series that you
did here with the
the female and the different heads that
that kind of
pop over her i think if you did a couple
of different women
and the different animals you would do
it as a series
and i think that would sell well because
i i think also
doing one-off is okay but if you're able
to create like
like a show right in a show you have to
have themes and and different subjects
that you you do a couple of different
ways
and then that's what people really get
into
because i don't just want to buy a one
piece i want to buy like a triptych
yeah the other way you can determine
whether or not you want to do a style or
not is just look at the amount of
engagement you get on a post
sometimes we're kind of blind to
our own work we don't know what's good
or bad and then all of a sudden we see
people responding like crazy like
wow that one was so easy to do but they
really love that one
and then give them a little bit more of
that and test that theory and if you're
able to do that the audience is very
smart
now i have this theory okay you want to
cut away from this i have this theory
every time i go to one of these art
galleries these small art galleries
obviously
where i can actually afford to buy the
artwork that's on the wall
i walk around and the thing that catches
my eye
almost always actually it's been always
this way
already sold out how did that happen
the one piece i want to buy is already
sold out there's already a red dot on it
because i think there's something about
this group intelligence like when you
walk into a show fresh and you don't
know anything about the artwork
your eyes can be drawn to something and
usually for me
it's usually color and shape like i'm
drawn
to it because you have to remember when
people buy art they have a spot in their
house somewhere in mind or their office
or
something like that and they're looking
for something to complement
all that stuff and i know that's kind of
like horrible for me to say but you
kind of have to take a little bit into
consideration but people are buying to
to beautify their home and if they live
in a modern house if they live in
one of those reclaimed homes that's got
all that old wood and
steel they're gonna want something else
so they're drawn in by the color
and whatever general shape and
composition and then it's everything
else
so if you can figure that out and know
who your customer and your buyers are
you would just give them that and they'd
come in and you sell out
and after your first sellout show you
just double your price and you'd keep
doing that until people
stopped buying everything yeah
totally um yeah i think you know making
like
beautiful like beautiful is is important
like to me anyway like i mean there's
there's a conceptual side but you know
making beautiful stuff
eventually it's like something super
important
yeah so now i've also noticed here in
one of your
clips here on instagram you're drawing
the cap
you're using procreate oh yeah so
sometimes you use procreate
i just got started i'm not that great
using procreate um but
it's really fun yeah i mean i really
enjoy it
and yeah it seems like people are uh
searching for
this type of uh tutorials and stuff
so yeah i definitely want to do more
but uh yeah i did like
just a couple of these processes with my
ipad
i'm definitely faster with like with
photoshop so
yeah it takes time to get used to it but
yeah
i think yeah it's the fact that you can
take it with you anywhere is
amazing like if you did a series of like
three cats
or three dogs or wolves or whatever
or three creatures if you keep doing
that and you show that on your instagram
i think the audience is going to tell
you right away we want more of this
pierre
we're in love with that and i would do
that yeah that's
that's interesting yeah look guys here's
the deal
he has 21 000 followers this number
needs to go up like now
all right you guys go check out his work
it's pierre underscore client house
show him some love he's not going to
bomb you with like crazy stuff he's just
going to
beautify your your feed on instagram
that's it okay let me cut out of this
boom okay so let's oh now you're adding
so i'm just trying like i don't know
what i'm doing basically but
this whole time yeah i'm just
yeah you're doing what you're doing you
know by adding some of those lines
and and curving them the way that you do
you're making the teeth not look flat
they look more dimensional and rounded
i like what you're doing i'm trying to
would you say jonah
i like what he did on the nose
oh yeah i totally like cooking this one
i didn't have any idea what i'm doing
i didn't even look at the reference i
yeah
close this one off but um yeah the teeth
teeth are always tricky yeah because i'm
doing something kind of stylized and
it's not really
skulls doesn't really look like that so
right i don't know it's kind of like a
squid skull
like from what's that film pirates of
the caribbean
that guy who comes out oh yeah captain
whatever captain octopus face
yeah he's beard yeah like tentacles yeah
yeah
yeah i mean that's okay okay i wonder if
we need like a
shadow like underneath everything maybe
it will make things
a bit more interesting yeah now i
haven't eaten all day
so i think i have like five more minutes
of energy before i pass out here guys
so uh pierre's gonna do what he can to
take us home but then of course if he
needs to work on this i'd love to see
this finished in whatever way that you
consider finish somewhere
so that people can tune in and see the
final final right it's tough to work
under pressure on live when
a couple hundred people are watching you
yeah totally yeah we can uh we can wrap
this up
and yeah i think we made a nice progress
mm-hmm now did you just add a shadow
behind the skull
yeah yeah i'm searching for the drawing
and i don't remember where you put it
with all these layers but oh there it is
yeah
i'm gonna have this one as well
i think it's gonna be oh there it is
yeah
very nice so it's interesting you're
simultaneously flattening it out by
adding a like a 2d
shadow but you added dimension by
creating a lip or an
edge to the parts where his nose and his
eyes are cut out
some interesting decisions that you're
making there
a lot of people have asked this question
before how do you find your style how do
you find your style and i always point
to the same reference
back in the day when image comics was
like the juggernaut of the comic book
industry
i forget who said this it probably was
todd mcfarlane but he said style
style is basically making the same
mistake repeatedly
so if you draw realistically like the
masters
for the renaissance right there wasn't a
whole lot of style
maybe if you're caravaggio you're
lighting with that tone of brussels
lighting
the corner like cheek highlight right
and it's very dramatic and vivid and
that's his style and you can see it and
you can recognize it
but as you get into more modern and
contemporary art
it's like when they draw the hand
differently or they make the eyes bigger
or the nose smaller
that style and saying like you know what
this is shorthand this is an
abbreviation for what a nose would look
like
and and manga and anime are like that
that
up pointed nose or just like three lines
that represent
the shading of where the nose would be
that style
so i'm william i mean i i'll tell you
even a secret
about like my own style i mean i had a
tough time making
nice looking lines like just to draw
with the tablets
yeah yeah i now i have this uh plugin
that makes it smooth but
um i because i because of that like as i
was
practicing i just uh stopped using like
lines and now i'm just deleting all my
lines
um when i work and that's like the
limitation like just a stupid limitation
of working on my computer kind of forced
its way to my style
so so wait a minute you're using some
plug-in to help you draw smoother
curvier and ice curve lines yeah it's
called
lazy nazumi wait what is it right here
laziness okay can you see that
um not on my screen but jonah can see it
yeah yeah
yeah and yeah it has like a few
different options here i'm just
doing something that makes it smoother
and that's
basically it if you're using affinity
designer there's a pretty nice
feature that kind of stabilize your
brush so you don't have to do that
oh but in photoshop it's nicer than
the red i mean you can you can add some
smoothing here
in photoshop yeah i see that i don't
really like that me neither i don't know
i've tried it it doesn't seem to work
it's not as good as the one in procreate
right
when you use that assistant yeah
so procreate and infinity designer have
this figured out but for photoshop
i'll use this plugin so okay so anyway
yeah that's
just because of that limitation like as
you said like the mistakes
becomes like a part of your style
yeah i just couldn't figure out how to
do lines so
that's my style now i guess
um yeah i guess that's it okay pretty
much i mean yeah
it's not finished but uh we can stop
here yeah okay so a couple things look
at that you guys first of all
you just rewarded yourself by making it
to the end of the live stream because he
just dropped a little secret plug-in
that even know about to make your line
smoother
so if you want to get into this and
you're
unconfident or not confident about your
line quality that's a great plugin we'll
include that in the notes below because
i couldn't see it but
i know jonah did and that's awesome and
i want to also say thank you to
like again i don't know how to pronounce
your name it's abiori or abori or
something like that thank you very much
for your super chat
pierre i love that you you're so brave
to do this live very few people are
willing to do this stuff kind of live
and it takes a long time and to walk and
chew gum and draw and think and do all
that stuff
it's a feat right it really is so thank
you for doing that
um and we're going to wrap up the show i
want to let people know
who we've been talking to in case for
whatever reason you've only been joining
us in the last 10 minutes or so
his name is pierre kleinhouse he's based
out of israel
and he's an illustrator graphic designer
you guys can work with him if you wish
and if you see this work and you love
his style go check him out
on social at on instagram at pierre
underscore cline house go to his website
and also check out his youtube channel
and subscribe
like comment do all the stuff you guys
know that you need to do and that's it
for us everybody thank you very much
and um i guess we'll see you guys next
time thanks for being a part of our one
billion mission
that's it for us thanks for being part
of the donation and i will see you guys
later i gotta play this song cuz i'm a
little rusty